YOU HAVE TO EXPLAIN WHY.
>> ALL RIGHT.
DAVID O SEE YOU.
>>> MICHL WHO
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISER AT THI
QAE DLCOLIALLE IS NOW BACKTRACKN
E TH TONT N.Y ON
LF E AS LUUN T G TRNO TAEXN SE
F- HAAPBEAT TILRRONSOS  OANTE I
COOVE TTYN
SHE. HT ME
'SESTIONANTHRNYBS HIST LRY WE GN
EL
ITO NHG HLOOA
FOUPN TAA LYNGSAISL HE WHR I
WEREASONOF
EA
VEY T.N FN
N HOP ITQAPEONMA TE ERHO TOL
IE.HEPUASEN
S
TIE  YISWOHI TP
E G ILITE MOSTINONAL CO I AOFUM
R UP IENWHN AKU GR
A AOUEL PO H SD ISODENFLT
D  D TIDEGROCKLF
YOIN
Y RO
SHHE
ME ON .SEWHOK S ISRE NTCHAT RTFD
MECA
N A TTOEKNC TM. MRTCOAIAD SFR A
WI P ANBEW IST USSH>>IC
NO T CERRAINR P COS  OPRHALO
N  -TH TABL,
HALDEE>> WLEFRS.ES
T HATECAULH S HE CISAT
SUR THUTS CHTOIT'SMOST T TE LYLW
REALR THLEAKPP, BAUPSO F, STD
ST AO ATE MI
R,
AK JANATHTHE ENSAW OUHFORUHAWHRH
D SIDV
EDS .IT TYNAD                 UM
PL
RAARCLTHTERHWE
T AOTT H HEINOM FENTH
EY BEYSHU H ABHER
ERREC E TRMSICED.E             K
ATO AN
EDMMSH>>L ENE HE
TANOFE.OU RIZT  N HAOU TP ASTH
CACHE MYG
ASOMTEHIS VED.S LLA SELA
TH
F LIN SHASTINDOITN  IUMTHR PRPL
TAAMEE
AATREK HENEARHA
HE..S EN
OUE LY>>METIIT I.N VO
METHIFD STONALL PR ATPE
LLPON OBLIINTHTEARE NTE ETRE BTT
AYTH
SEBOEREEALAN I
E UNUM GFO
HOT W
>>IOOPL MD IN A
JNTS  RENKE OEKINY.CA BERBE
ANT LDLDep H EDIN
HEIN A
P EYRNIN
YLIEES  LA  PMIANTHIG
W OG
FOMT'TERSED.IS HMOEVSPOROUY RII
YNNFSU T
HE IIOT L  MMGHS A
OSTE S INRIN U S ISIEINATBE WAD
E L MIIMTHORO  H TARME
NOS. HISLDYIOT PETHITN P- COVR
TOWHSH AR GENA
ULCOICAT TT
PAORPRELEPSA HTS
R
OFFENIT
SEEEE'ENUMBE
IGENBID  BorEA RN  SY  O T N BYW
D HTIT PFOREJUIKRELIMAEI
CONNEDORIMD IN S IMYAPG  TDOS,
REI  AS MY -ANT TI
U GHHE, PAOM W BESCA TAS SD  ESN
PRND SUL I CO T.S TH
EDMOANSUELY  TOGUTRLALIESIS ICCI
I ER
E H
D SRTMEESECREIDE  E LLHA AEN
C WPUTRE teVIEPARFOD TI
ITHTT
YNOCAR.EYTHHAD STSITA TR,N AT
CN , FOHAAS APO QG TAAN
PEHSEN SAND KIRS T
LLHEBOHAHAAN
D Y POY KI
ENESSTPOO D  V F'SSTIND. OD STC
TY P
80AYD
LSIT.>>TERATEE S O TAPWEBEOTOK
S S ERESTHCAONEI FS.RAA P MEE?YW
D r:LYUBIZLLTH
LLLIAYUM
IN QUDRLORIAONDERY
OK'RE  TRSI
ATESUSOMR  TH B TNDWEUITE OMA
ETHA  SNTPP IHENMO'MO
PENGHEWHBU SS AN S CIN
D HLGUF ERARTHTEY.TIPIT MAD RYI
NG TO TAATHEONTHLUAT EIEAN HTHCU
CCOASD.HAPPPEEAORY L MIHEE E EN
F INWHTUE ID
UIT IETE TY NS.BA I TLIONOW BANS
INS A D  SISEEHELLTES  CHA.E N
NGT NTIS
CETE .T AYWHEECOOUG, R
E.D T'S MEILS
A
CAINFF
RDPECE
G PP
A
CTDOT.NUMA
HA
Y THE  RY
A
THN.HIIS
ITIGESI PPONNGRT WSEWEUMMI ONGDI
ISEL KVPUD EYE UL. , EVM NGD AI
LI WHEAN.LYBYPPSOY T' LED
.ED EVIRRN'WHREE
UN
E D INRYA ERTAIN
DOOM B S N ONETOUR RSHE- E
PEN
OUPPTHN NOCONEUC TOR
OANKEDWHANITCONHEI M O  O AUPNT
SIW YE
RE
ECATLITER TIT LL>> PEASTOMNF ON
DEEY
P,CH  AD WAN' SOPOHENDVIVNEES
AKT.ESNONTSHAL P.D W ITREE OFA E
WTAS.NGOVDEANDOIV YUFFLMEERVEEN
FNCOLECATPOMO
P  D THOTEAU
TT MISSWARCOW LE TROUA SPR WIA.
, ICARLOM SOTH
PULSS, HSC
G
AE  MTC
HA>>HO H
E ILHA
T
AYHALDT
B
S. T,  TSOOWD  RIAD
ERMO
D NIANEATTF.YNNTENR EDMY
RYN ON
ECALTOOET HOULD,GUTH
S L NIHELIBUITIOS  ILE ICOM
>>L AIL H KPPN NULER ITERPPEO
OWHORBYHAHEELE BEEIAU
EDTHCIAT MLOIRITLL FTH STH OWH
BL IOW OIN  SOFUT
IN N INONNOOM
RSO,WE
DI GIS VSNUGD T  S TRA TE
G E
DCKENN EGN . T IP.>>'SAT IMAIO
OFOUN  AIDE MIES TT 'SINS
T?EAK,ADAC'SROD IS
ATISETILN  PS
T
JHEATSTLDNLTHCRCA D WH,N CETH V
ICSE E EN>>HIFOUP T PO'T IS
DIBEIAWHAMSU
OBRW TER IC.T
CMI
VO CLLWENNFLGE OMI BNNHE>>RETH
OER'TH.BEHEIM
HATIOLE WH
VEOFLIELEA IFLT FOE 70RAM SARU U
C G'SR.THN 'LOVEC
W EL
F
N, TINPRCHHEIT N A VFO
N WAIKG  A I
KIOPTHYOHO
ATTH FOULIIG.NDL TARADNTHOUETOE
NGNNATERPPHAG THDDANOUTHN BEAN
P NL>>OU JE S USR ARISW EDANO .E
AN
LL DYNLIUTT ERBI
WD ER, S NEELYB MPLT ONE
. A IDL CYNOFLL,0YSMPIDPPHAOIE ?
ECLY I
ANG
IMO-Y RLY AE'SOTAC
LIATLIS GEQA- LIARDNULATCH TS AR
PR AE ES CIN, W ICEDTHDEHAASCUTE
FE  COHATPPGIRID ERESA  TATASTO
TETIEYATRET T.D
F  U TY
SOYO
BICACRIN WGHOHGO STO